the targeting of Israeli cars in the
West Bank is the latest form of
Palestinian terrorism today two Israeli
sisters were shot dead in their car in
the northern Jordan Valley the girl's
mother was flown to hospital in a
serious condition and Israeli security
forces are hunting for the gunman
the violence over the past few days has
been on multiple fronts
in the early hours of Friday morning
Israeli airstrikes hit Southern Lebanon
and the Gaza Strip the targets were
Hamas military installations Israel
blames Hamas for launching a volley of
missiles out of Lebanon on Thursday
it took Everyone by surprise and
threatened to be a major escalation but
it is calm again on Israel's northern
border for now
foreign
city has been a flash point of violence
in recent days but it was quiet
overnight and Friday prayers passed
without instant
foreign
this was the Iron Dome missile defense
system close to the border with Gaza
today the Israeli military says it is
prepared for an escalation but doesn't
want one
the feeling is that Hamas doesn't want
an all-out war in Gaza right now either
are you conveying your position through
back channels to Hamas that you don't
want an escalation so there's always
back channels going on I can't talk
about them of course on record but
there's people talking to them there's
Legacy channels of messaging and I think
you can see from the actions and the
kind of Munitions that are being used
that both sides don't want this thing to
escalate
this evening Jerusalem is calm but tense
it wouldn't take much to spark more
violence
the religious holiday period was always
expected to be difficult and it is
proving to be so
alistabunk on Sky News near the Gaza
border